il faut faire attention parce qu'on nous
a dit qu'il fallait respecter on
respecte alors les gens ils ont pas
respectées - j'estime qu'il faut
respecter sa première fois que je sors
depuis qu'on a qu'on nous a dit de
respecter parce que j'avais besoin de
médicaments sinon ce serait pas sorti tu
vois quand même assez souvent même en
bas de gauche à beat deschamps qui
traînent ils sont à plusieurs ils sont
collés on a quand même donné des
consignes strictes
avant-hier quand je suis allée faire des
courses pareil ça est grand répéter
répéter les jambes à la caisse moyen
dame qui me collait je suis dit écoutez
madame il ya des mesures de voilà une
vous regardent de travers
les français sont trop désobéissants
donc à un moment donné il faut aussi
sanctionner quoi s'il ya au moins une
fois dia tout le monde respecte moi mais
il ya au moins 10 % qui sont sans nos
papiers détestation sent le truc est en
fait sans course mais mans où j'habite
lie mon ami sort souvent pour rien on
fait des yeux pas de 10% ce papier mais
oui sauf le tessin et le pari que ftf
l'épée au commissariat et tout
regardez il disait on s'en fout et il
s'en faut de nous même pas de grand mais
pas de rien mais pas de même de même mon
insistance il appelle elle me répondait
pas ils sont restreints et tout comme je
vous dis sincèrement on est dans la
merde mais moi je suis en train de
chercher un appartement vide pour
l'ouvrir